ماذا تفعل اذا اقتحم الثعلب مكتبك اثناء
ساعات دوامك الرسميه هذا ليس من الخيال
هذا ما حدث فعلا حيث اقتحم ثعلب مكاتب
تابعه لوزاره النفط العراقيه واظهر مقطع
فيديو طريق الضيف غير المتوقع وهو يتجول
بين المكاتب والمقاعد محاولا الاختباء خلف
الملفات على الارفف وبدا الثعلب خائفا من
اصوات الموظفين التي سمعت بالفيديو
حصيني
بالوزاره
[موسيقى]
2023 السعوديه بعد تعطل مركبتهم في الرمال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصديق وقت الضيق مقوله مرتبطه بصدق
العلاقه بين الاصدقاء تعني ضروره وقوف
الانسان مع صديقه في الضراء قبل السراء
وهذا ما قام به ثلاثه شبان مع صديقهم
المصاب بالسرطان في محافظه اربد شمال
الاردن مقطع فيديو مؤثر انتشر بشكل واسع
في الاردن حيث يقوم الشبان الثلاثه بحلاقه
شعرهم بشكل كلي تضامنا مع صديقهم الذي تم
تشخيص اصابته بالسرطان
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
[تصفيق]
لا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولا يهمك
ضجه واسعه في العراق لمعلمه عراقيه تقع
انتشار مقطع فيديو في مدرسه بمحافظه
البصره الجنوبيه وكانت تلوم تلاميذها
الصغار لعدم وضع الاعجاب لصفحتها وزير
التربيه والتعليم العراقي ابراهيم الجبوري
تدخل على الفور وطالبتفتح تحقيقا ومحاسبتي
المعلمه
عليك
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله